[Music]
welcome back two careful boys where we
are very very careful boys sponsored by
joombi
but the record is no more bro
yeah that was crazy what specific thing
caused it to be careful we don't want to
get canceled again yeah you see really
seriously it's a new era of jk news
and i think that we have to change with
the times
you know what i mean like
everyone's careful these days yeah who
ask us any edgy question this is a safe
place anything this is a safe ask him
any edgy question he's good he's good
try bart that's right
every edgy question i'll work my way up
to you
work your way down to me
it's a new time it's a new era any
careful questions for the boys uh
careful questions i feel like i'm gonna
get canceled for asking kids
way to be careful
okay this guy gets it
yeah it's his mother be careful not ask
after all this is a heavily sponsored
show
so
we have to watch out for our sponsors
too because we don't want them to be
canceled because of us yeah that's very
true careful boys we need to get
sponsored by band-aids or something to
be extra careful baby proof outlets or
something
would be good hey forks that retract
when you try to put them in a
outlet
i just try to stick it into a steak and
doesn't even stick
you can't use it but at least you can't
use it yeah it's true
non-choking hazards there's no utility
to this fork yeah that's fine let's try
to get broccoli we should have a locking
mechanism for it but i guess yeah dude
that's a great brand i did always want
to uh come up with the because i'm a fan
of sporks i know not everybody likes
wack i just feel like i just feel like
they weren't done right because i feel
like sports is not enough fork and not
enough spoon but if you made a spoon
that had a retractable wolverine style
fork that if you just push the button
the fork would come out
then i'd be like i think that's really
practical not make it disposable [ __ ]
oh
or a big washable white guy
oh
[ __ ] why would i need to wash it if it's
disposable [ __ ]
be careful
[Laughter]
have you ever had that camping tool
where it's a spoon on one side and a
fork on the other yeah but nobody wants
a flashlight for eating fleshlight what
are you talking about oh a flashlight on
one side a fork on the other yeah
remember when bart talked about eating a
fleshlight guys that's what i'm saying
what what did you say about that no no i
didn't what you ate a fleshlight careful
boy i looked i got so horny i wanted to
eat it
that's and that's your free that's your
wardrobe yeah
hey has that ever happened do you think
someone's ever actually ate out of him
yes
you would also think that if guys are
willing to sniff panties because it
might be remnants of like a female's
vegeta but that's what you also sniff
would you also sniff her dildo oh i
thought you mean like eating it out
after you jizz in it i'm like those are
two different things yeah those are i'm
going onto the guy's candy thing i would
never eat up the fleshlight after i
[ __ ] in it but before before but
you're pregnant are you hating on it
because this is we got to be careful
about that yeah and i respect you
[Laughter]
hey man that's pretty cool
you come a long
you're very sex-positive dude bart has
been super sex positive i feel like bart
is at the forefront of sex positivity in
this group
if you're saying it it's true he's
[ __ ] out there petitioning for
fleshlight voters right
voter rights very specific what the hell
is that hey way to have his back on that
one yeah what the [ __ ] hey
you're approved bro you're a pretty dog
you're a king chamber yo
don't be a king shame don't do you think
there's discrimination between the
different
fleshlight accessories like the mouth
doesn't like the anus and the [ __ ] is
like they're like the priority number
one and there's like different rankings
users don't like each other no like the
fleshlights when they battle each other
out you know like when they're alone
like toy story story like the museum
yeah it's like sex toy story i get it
now that i mean like sex toy story
and then the [ __ ] is great who's woody
who's woody what
how could you even think it's not woody
forget about all flesh lines let's let's
incorporate all sex toys so dildo then
so like you know the dog remember the
dog that was like the slinky yeah you'd
be anal beads you know he'd be animals
he'll be kinky
he just stays a dog
because i'm open i'm not being an
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah if you want to be
inclusive you don't change any of the
characters mr blowtato head buzz
lightyear would be the he'd be the dark
knight because that's like the new hot
sex toy on the block he doesn't know
what the dark knight is oh dude you know
the dark knight
look at his face the dark knight is a
sex toy
the most amazing thing ever planet earth
ryan dude what's going on bro
hey don't even show them we should just
get them one together everybody just
chip in dude we should try to get
sponsored by the dark knight you guys
never heard of the dark knight bro we're
giving them so much free presses
the problem is it's okay if you want
real sponsorship uh it's the dark knight
it's a product by sohimi s-o-h-i-m-i
check it out they have a bunch of
amazing products on there this is not
because we're talking about fleshlights
but i think this is the next level thing
is it just a big dark dildo it doesn't
work for you it's true you're ready
it's about to be out of a job oh it's
for boys it's like it's like imagine
imagine it's for boys
for men all right imagine this right i
want you to imagine
a sea slug inside of a pringles
canister
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of your dick but
the sea slug yeah it just loves the sea
slug opens up sucks your dick and
rotates and turbines on you like an
alligator trying to drag you in we have
googled this so much the past 48 hours
that it came up in auto complete
when i started typing the dark knight
the dark knight male masturbator auto
completed for me so it's like christian
bale this is version 3.0 why is it
called the dark knight but it makes you
empty your entire nut sack in one
balloon it feels like batman is beating
your dick
first of all cushion bale too yeah the
christian belt it's like a batman toy
it's like it comes out of a batmobile oh
it's hit so you can hide it i'm going to
show you this it's actually on his
utility belt i'm going to show you this
but you have to have a level of maturity
we're not trying to king shame here no
king shamers no king chambers oh now i
have to be the mature one after you guys
describe this oh you got to show it
while it's working first that's a wild
explanation though the cool thing is
there's a suction cup this looks like a
freaking shock for an integra it looks
like a telescope
i like how it you know it just feels
like fast and furious
oh my gosh
that is crazy
wow
oh it's too aggressive
look at swamp wow
it's gone now
it ate it wow this is wild can you
handle that your description was on
point i told you it's like a sea slug
can i handle it
what's happening now
wow
the textile ones are cool but it floats
too
oh that's how you wash this oh that's
that's what you do
what if in the future guys thought being
turned on by girls and slow-mo [ __ ] like
this makes them horny
i can see right now yeah
so there you go is it moving it's moving
oh it's on a rotator thing you guys have
tried using it we don't even we just
found out like a couple days ago we'll
see you the next shoot my my tracking
number says it's coming in two days
with this article we started talking
about uh we started talking about this
whole movie the brown bunny that was
bringing up right about this one shake
and so so i'm like sitting over there as
a host and i'm trying to look up this
clip yeah and then obviously you can't
find the clip of it unless you go to
like xvideos.com or anything so i'm
literally on google i'm looking on the
second page of search options it says x
video so like click that one to find the
clip we click it and the clip is nothing
it blows our mind it's the ad next to it
and which is the dark knight it's this
it's this thing but
did it not get anything i found it dude
that's good
jesus christ dude it's the dark knight
that's chloe's significantly by the way
the fact that it's wall mounted is
pretty crazy because it probably doesn't
need to be wall mounted i'm just mad
that it took this long for something
like that to come out it might have just
taken this long for that to be
mainstream because it could have been
like a whole underground i couldn't find
a manufacturer like
anybody want to make this for me can you
mass produce this they go to shark tank
check it out
i want to see the guy who invented this
and i want to buy the company dude
and then i want to take it to shark tank
you guys ready to pitch it it's time
cuba's gonna love it dude
but we wanna we gotta go in there and be
like we don't want mr wonderful
that's chloe
you guys tired of this we're
playing the clip for yourself
i'm not doing anything dude
i was just trying to show you this cool
sex toy
why are you making it weird see this is
why we can't have everyone else yeah
sorry
today's video is brought to you by
upstart if looking at your credit card
statement just makes you want to scream
into the boy like i'm going out of
control
you're not alone that's why upstart is
here to help you see the light at the
end of the tunnel how nice of them
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online whether you're paying off credit
cards or consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get one fixed monthly payment i know
i have upstart knows you're more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and current employment to help you get a
smarter rate for your loan with a five
minute rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans from one thousand to
up to fifty thousand dollars wow
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after your acceptance very
fast find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today by going to
upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record and don't forget to use the
url so they know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined by your
credit your income and other certain
information that you put on your
application make sure you go check out
upstart.com off the record
thank you we gotta we gotta go back to
doing that thing where uh hey we should
one whole episode we don't talk about
dicks oh yeah we need a dick
how do we get to dicks again it's off i
mean it's careful boys this is a problem
that's what bothers me though right so
we're just trying to talk about this
this really super sex positive [ __ ]
scene that we were watching yesterday
and then he's laughing at it right now
he's actually laughing at
this actress's performance i'm just glad
because nobody could see it but him
that's a jerk bro steve just playing it
to watch her by himself i'm not doing
anything dude i'm literally just showing
you this ad you know
you know that's very offensive
it's so offensive that like
you're just giggling out there and
laughing at a beautiful human experience
so she works hard to prep for a role
he's talking about the dude in the ad
he's talking about the dude oh okay i
wonder if the people who like make dark
knight in the [ __ ] lab are giggling
while they put it together
they have to be dude yeah or they just
get fired maybe they're really
passionate about their project you know
they needed to call it something else
like the dick grappler or something oh
yeah that's so much better dude the dick
wrapper yeah cause it's like i don't
know it's doing some sort of grappling
on your feet the dark knight is also red
like why is it right that's true why is
it called the dark knight maybe it's
because it's like
you know not the hero you like want but
it's the hero you need
there it is dude wow anthony lee pulled
it from half bro we really didn't get
it that was very good you know what's
scary about that
is the intensity of
that when you're nutting because i i'm
gonna rush to turn that [ __ ] off yeah as
soon as you bust you're like
that's why it's it's mounted on wall so
you can pull out oh
but doesn't it pull you back in
it might work
that thing might pull you back in bro
i'm not [ __ ] twisting you're just
like rotating around you turn into a
spinner bruh
the arm looks like this like it's
[ __ ] pulling your ass back into it
you don't [ __ ] the dark knight it [ __ ]
you it sure looks like it too there's
some rpms there's gonna be a lot of
lawsuits against uh the payouts are
going to be sick them from [ __ ] dc
about dude
do you feel like flashlights looking at
this this competition for dicks around
the world then it's like we need to add
the rotation to our fleshlight material
for sure they have to they have to do
this this one's called the acme joy
right here act me joy i want to see sex
toy companies like battle it out oh like
what if they have like press events like
that like apple when they do the
unveiling of the new iphone
they have like a steve jobs equivalent
like talking about the new technology
for the dark knight that would be pretty
cool i'll be right back steve [ __ ]
steve [ __ ]
this is what you do every time your
screens turn towards you and they can't
see it that's hilarious he's just
putting on gangbang board and everything
i
that's absolutely not true
there's an excel spreadsheet here where
i i mark what videos we did and when and
what's a hot topic right you got to be a
little more mature you got to be a
little mature if you're going to sit in
the hot seat bro like you're not really
acting you're right i'm not being
careful
he's trying to work i hate orgasmic
pleasure
just put the laptop running from let's
talk about some serious stuff i'm trying
to do a professional job here
and i don't appreciate that it's one of
the most important things your mom ever
taught you oh that's so weird to hear
that
yeah what are some of those lessons
that watch the show and they look up to
us right now there's someone at the
hospital
they're dealing with a terminal illness
and this is their only way
of joy yeah
and we're the only reason why they're
going to recover okay so you need to
take this serious right you don't come
to the show
and giggle at the gang bangs
especially the dark knight you just need
to be more professional right now
overall dude and they're looking at you
for
for support they're looking at you for
inspiration yeah they come to the show
for the real [ __ ] okay and that's the
most important job of the guest too to
be the relative element for you know the
people watching at home so bring it back
to his sister kind of being a dick right
now
you're going to be an [ __ ] right now
ryan can i just take a picture of you
i just want you to see this later do you
want me to keep my mouth open
actually just [ __ ] look at it right
now holy [ __ ]
this is what you look like to me right
now
while you're asking me about my sister
there's a full hog gang bang all right
happening right in there
and you can see
joe's skin right here too
you see my [ __ ] [ __ ] you should
record joe's terminal illness uh speech
again just with that
on the background what the [ __ ] is going
on
i don't get it listen there's so many
orifices on this [ __ ] screen dude
if you had them in a biker bar
did you type that part
it just came it was the next video
autoplay
oh so [ __ ] here's the thing
if you have the misfortune of not being
on the patreon the patreon is where you
get to see
what's going on it's cool stuff yeah
it's into a jk ad
just having the channels back
someone's got to stick up for the
channel while this guy's trying to tear
it all down don't keep me in the photos
ryan get me out of here yeah put him in
the photos he needs it he needs it that
that is true because on youtube we're
careful boys but on patreon we're wow
boys this is as careful as it's gonna
get it's pretty careful
the thing is you got the porn facing you
not to them yeah front-facing porn only
uncareful well we don't know if there's
porn back there only we're only taking
ryan's words it's a legend you kind of
photoshopped something really quick it's
50 50. you're just the dude who said
there are so many orifices
no i just meant like in general like
like nothing like sexual yeah
yeah yeah i think working in porn
destroys the magic of porn
like in the like in movies like we love
movies he destroys the flavor of chicken
yeah you don't want to eat there didn't
our friend cat say that um her guy kind
of got yeah he's a specialist yeah yeah
that's true and he was important he's
not horny no more well he didn't get
that horny after he's not a horny boy no
though yeah yeah
but what are you gonna do oh that's
weird sometimes you get jaded you know i
guess yeah the the the
facade is gone well she also said too
because she takes like
like pictures of her feet and stuff yeah
and like she's doing like sex
work during the day or whatever you call
it like when you're taking pictures of
your feet and taking like sexy photos of
yourself and then she is less in the
middle yeah secondly not sex work but
yeah sure well you know what i mean like
like or titillation work okay yeah
yeah let's see
and she's not in the mood as much
because surely like exactly that's what
she's talking about she already has been
doing titillation [ __ ] all day because
our uh like food blogging friends said
the same thing about food like the
relationship of food started feeling
like oh i'm not that
i don't want to do no more [ __ ] gotta
do it every day
and i'm oh it's like this show when i do
this show and i go home i don't [ __ ]
want to talk to my girl
i don't talk shame
i don't want to see any more asians yeah
yeah i have a no asian thing i don't
want to watch any game being poor when i
go home
out here
too much porn at jk news i don't want to
go to a biker bar after this no
my usual spot
so that means
don't pursue your passion
pursue what you already hate
because if you join what you hate you
already hate it anyway that's really
good and then you keep all the things
you love
for a lifetime or if you're an addictive
person
then heavy going to the thing you're
addicted just to even get over it hey
dude my dad never wanted to go to his
job he [ __ ] needed a job so that's a
good point and he did great and did for
a long time way too long nearly killed
him
damn sorry it's hard to focus because
the tricks getting game day
while he's talking about yeah my dad
jumped and nearly killed them that's
just good mad libs bro you're good at
you're gonna improv though yeah
yeah you're just good at that
have you seen this guy jk means this guy
this guy is a master of with his own jk
party tomorrow you know she's here we
should play a [ __ ] random portal clip
and he's gotta score it
oh that's good score no score no score
no dude
oh sorry it's a music porno
well that one's not as bad wait till we
get to the climax you know what i'm
saying
i think i found a new jk party challenge
uh tell a speech about your favorite
moments with your mom
while watching oh that's good that's
actually
watching before that's
and then everybody else has to just hold
your eyeballs open like this the whole
time so you're just like focus on it
memories okay can we actually just do it
because i swear to god if i show up at
party and we just play the same two
games i'm gonna be [ __ ]
pissed all right we played mad gabs
again i swear to god my [ __ ] brain
you know what matt gabs is good at good
for nothing it doesn't help you with
[ __ ] mad gap matt gabs is [ __ ] what
is the porn mom speech
focus concentration
yeah okay this these are all things you
need in your life need that put the
blinders on okay he's hot holding a
giant dildo sharpie it's magnum okay it
says magnum on here that's actually
really good that's crazy we're gonna
evolve jk party dude you just wait guys
that's pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you